[Music]  ulcers - such a good season want to  touch on the reunion the proudest  achievement of my career has been to  provide a platform that has launched the  careers of 100 queens to international  stardom now what you decide to do with  that platform is up to you and tonight  one queen decided not to join us or as  tatyana would say choices were you  disappointed that fifi didn't show up I  know you know everybody does their own  thing for their own reasons you know  they're all my beautiful children  they're all complicated and and diverse  I love them all it's a family good bad  sure you know we all come from a family  I love all my kids I love them all  [Music]  you